countries across europe are introducing
a new round of coronavirus restrictions
they're coming in either just before
christmas or soon after
italy is the latest country to announce
new measures shops
bars and restaurants there will close
and travel between different regions
will be banned
similar precautions are being taken
across the continent
a pause on public life across europe
shuttered shops and empty streets in
germany
as the country goes into its first
weekend of hard lockdown
this winter
austria will follow suit just after
christmas
non-essential businesses will close on
december 26th
austria's coronavirus infection rate is
lower than many of its neighbors
but there are fears that could change
since we are not an island and have
people coming in from other countries
we should prepare ourselves for the
possibility of exponential growth
at any time
sweden's infection rate on the other
hand has been surging for two months
the nordic country never imposed a full
lockdown
relying instead on voluntary social
distancing
but with case numbers going up
non-essential public facilities like
pools and libraries will close
and for the first time the government is
recommending residents wear masks on
public transport
yet the measures remain lacks compared
to germany and austria
a very serious lockdown for example
wouldn't have an effect in the long run
because people would not put up with
that switzerland too
is headed for lockdown as restaurants
are set to close next
week the swiss government has urged
people to stay inside
but has left at least one decision to
local authorities
whether to open ski lifts this year
skiers will have to add covert 19
to the long list of alpine hazards
and for more on this i'm joined by klaus
pumpus a journalist in
vienna klaus thanks for joining us
austria's tightening restrictions can
you give us the details
first of all we should be aware
everybody who wants to
enter austria from today on has to go
into carontine for 10 days he can test
himself free
after five days but first of all he has
to stay in carontine for
at least 5 days if not 10 days
second on 26th of december
so the second day of christmas
everything is suspended again
all shops are closed hotels and
restaurants are closed already now but
then all shops besides
food stores pharmacies and drugstores
will be closed
no museums are available up
to the 17th of january
austrians are afraid that the icu's will
be overloaded so they close everything
down again
third lock down in austria wow sounds
like a lot of
measures are being taken let me ask you
a multi-billion dollar question as
regards the ski industry switzerland
your country's neighbors letting
local authorities decide on whether to
open the ski lifts what is austria
deciding
it's the same the local authorities can
decide
whether they open or not and they will
open as we heard yesterday from salzburg
and as we've heard from tirolia for the
local people in the end because
no germans no italians no switz people
can enter
if they do so for example from bavaria
when they go back they have to go in
keratin as well for ten days so i
suppose nobody will come
to austria to go skiing besides the
austins themselves but they
must be aware there is no food there is
no drinks
there is no appreciate this season and
you can go
only up and down and when you go up in a
gondola
or a ski left you have to wear a mask
and not every seat may be filled
okay so it's going to be strictly skiing
ski season i suppose
can you help us understand what the
chancellor sebastian kurtz said when he
said austria
is not an island and has people coming
in when you're describing all these
complicated quarantine restrictions it
sounds like
it's becoming a bit of one he's afraid
that a lot of people living in austria
coming from the western balkans go home
on christmas
up to the 6th of january if you think of
serb orthodox people
and he's afraid they bring back more
infections as they did
partly in summertime these measures now
should be imposed in a way that nobody
really travels
and everybody stays home if this will
function we will see
later on but i doubt about the
functional ability of this
because not every bear control is so
maximized that you can exclude
infections coming in again into the
country
either from the south or from the north
of course it's always a struggle klaus
plumpers in vienna thank you for those
insights
you're welcome and for more on this i'm
joined by dr claudia hansen an
epidemiologist at the karolinska
institute in
stockholm uh thank you for joining us
doctor sweden
is tightening its restrictions what are
the new measures and
why the big change
good morning from stockholm uh the big
change is that the country is realizing
that the present strategy
does not really protect the the most
vulnerable and the old people
so they realize a bit that the
particularly the promise which was given
in the spring
that there wouldn't be a second wave
because of uh reached herd immunity
doesn't hold
so that is changing the public opinion
which is very important
i'm not sure whether the present
measures will really bring the case
numbers
tremendously down after hearing yeah
the government is now recommending that
passengers wear masks on public
transport but won't make them
mandatory will that work
i don't know they have been telling the
public two months
no two two to six months that must do
not work
i'm not sure how voluntary measure
now can can work in public transport it
it will become very difficult
and and your country as we heard in the
report it went it alone at the beginning
of the outbreak when other european
countries
lock down is can we now say that that
was the wrong approach
i personally think it's the wrong
approach and it's a it's a wrong
discussion to think about
lockdown and not locked down it is a
dynamic
disease that means if you do something
very short and decisive
very fast you benefit on the long run
so it's not about sustained lockdowns
it's about
a very decisive fast measures
at the right time which could help and
the public
in sweden would work on voluntary
measures it just needs to be explained
why and that has not been taken place
so is it a failure of communication on
the government's part
the government has been saying must do
not work the government hasn't said
that there is asymptomatic transmission
that means that you can
infect from somebody who doesn't know
that he's uh he's ill
there is no the uh the tracing test and
tracing
and isolating is is not well established
all this has not been communicated so
how can the
public make informed decision
it can't that's my opinion
okay dr claudia hanson an epidemiologist
at the karolinska institute
thanks for that
a second covid19 vaccine has been
authorized for emergency use in the
united states
millions of doses of the moderna vaccine
are expected to be added to the massive
american vaccination program
which began this week with healthcare
workers older
people in long-term care facilities are
next in line
the approval comes one week after the
u.s food and drug administration
authorized a vaccine developed by
biontech and pfizer
here's a look now at some of the latest
developments in the pandemic
german health departments reported 31
300 new cases on friday
and 702 fatalities related to covet 19.
twenty five thousand people have now
died of the disease
in germany in france the toll has passed
sixty thousand
president emmanuel macron is asking
people to remain vigilant after he
himself tested positive for covet 19.
australia puts parts of sydney under
lockdown to bring under control a
cluster near the city's northern beaches
people may leave their homes only for
work care exercise or basic necessities
and india surged past 10 million
coronavirus cases
the second highest in the world although
new infection rates appear to have
fallen
sharply in recent weeks
you